oh you
[Music]
can perfect
[Music]
what's up guys welcome back to the dope
as usual podcast i am thomas i am here
with marty o'neil drastic graphics
this is the dope as usual podcast we're
here to talk about life problems drugs
accomplishments and everything in
between today we have very special
guests
aida rodriguez comedian you may have
seen her on i saw the young turks show
can you
sorry before we start thank you for
coming on the show you appreciate it um
actually
yeah a little bit closer yeah better
okay cool yes i didn't want to mess mess
that up i watched i watched a lot of
your stuff yesterday
marty and i
i guess you could say we're politically
illiterate okay we have no idea what's
going on we have i've been
i'll tell you i was just selling drugs
my whole life and then we started doing
content and then i stopped so that's
pretty much where we're at baking soda
no no no not that drug
that's where i come from yeah where
where did you grow up i grew up in miami
florida i grew up yeah i lived in new
york but i grew up in miami so miami is
where i was raised and um it's so funny
because i grew up in like around drug
culture you know like
all drugs not just you know
weed and it's just so funny
it doesn't i don't like flinch it's just
like a perfect place to be this is life
you know what i mean like so you grew up
in miami's uh i'm assuming
i've never actually met anybody that
screw up miami
that saw the scarface era happen
how was that
so you know what's funny is maybe that
time
so it's weird because i'm puerto rican
and dominican and my stepfather's cuban
and we see
scarface and we're like yo why is this
italian dude
you know what i mean it just didn't it
wasn't it's it it was so funny because
it was so fascinating to everybody else
and for us you know if you love al
pacino he's such a great actor even with
carlito's way like he's he thought that
was kind of funny he didn't sound puerto
rican at all at all then you compare him
to like john leguizamo benny blanco from
the bronx and you're like they sound so
you know so and then luis guzman is
right there and you're like what is
going on but
you know we know now um you know it's
funny because i i was maybe a kid like
when that stuff was happening and i was
around it
and
it it was
man i i know people who
like they had this big scandal i know
people that were connected to like the
river cop scandal in miami where all
these cops got arrested for selling
drugs yeah oh i didn't know that yeah
big so and you know it was just part of
really interesting so part of the
cultural experience of miami like miami
drugs
um there was a connection with you know
a come up for people of color that
wasn't necessarily
you know the best because it's selling
drugs but it was it was the the come up
for some people who would probably never
ever see
a better lifestyle you know
wow see um i've never i mean obviously
i'm from california i grew up around
nothing but mexican people it is not the
same
at all my friends are from new york and
dominican and he's like no puerto rican
different he grew up in new york too so
he tells me the stories because all i
have all i know is
what mexican a few white guys
that's what i grew up around yeah so my
culture i'm very culturally just in a
box
most of us are though yeah i've never he
he tells me about you know he's like
puerto ricans are different because i
always thought i was like
the black dudes speak spanish
right yeah that's that well there are
many i never met a mexican person until
i until they moved here which is
mind-blowing i didn't even realize what
part of new york are you from oh buffalo
upstate so yeah no it's interesting um
it's funny because i have to i work to
unpack all of that stuff because there
are a lot of mexicans in new york uh
yeah uh [ __ ] uh what's his name what's
the little rainbow boy tekashi
that's a pretty is a big example you
know like but there are no i mean
not that he's the poster child but there
are a lot of mexicans now especially all
over the country like in areas like
tennessee and nashville
um
he was there last week that's why i
asked yeah no there are there there are
mexicans everywhere and um
it's interesting because the
puerto ricans dominicans and cubans are
caribbean so culturally
um there's a connection with the
caribbean which is you know that
includes all of the countries in the
caribbean they're island people right
they eat
you know they they have a lot of
things in common with people from like
jamaica and trinidad in terms of diet
and music and that kind of stuff
and then there's the the latinidad right
because um
we were colonized by spain and puerto
rico dominican republic and cuba but
then there are parts of the caribbean
that were colonized by the dutch and the
british
and uh the you know
the french which is whatever so they're
they're like it's so funny how we
intersect you know because mexicans and
puerto ricans speak spanish because they
were all colonized by spain but then
culturally there's like
uh
our indigenous people are you know the
thai knows the the arawaks and then
mexican people are like mayan and aztec
and inca so it's just very fascinating
for me to see how we intersect because
no matter what all of those things may
mean
to white racist people we just all
mexicans
look at the mexicans that are eating
five minutes get back over there
the first time i had a fried banana go
are you [ __ ] kidding me and then i
found out about other cultures yeah i
grew up around
uh do you know what merced by fresno
area yeah i know where it is it's just
you know drugs and fields so i didn't
really grow up around anybody
so
you just dropped more knowledge on me
than my history teacher or anybody ever
that's so funny devoid of your own
culture too like because the thing is
mexico is so big and it's so
cross-cultural there's so many cultural
cultures within the mexican
diaspora and so a lot of people you know
just assume that just because you're all
mexican that you are all the same and
even within when people say you know
we're not a mono a monolith mexicans are
not a monolith puerto ricans are not a
monolith like mexican there are mexicans
from the mainland that looked down at
mexicans that grew up here like you and
they call you gringos right oh we've
talked chicanos i don't speak my whole
family see spanish but me my mom and dad
got separate i used to be when i was a
kid but my mom wasn't gonna my mom's
doesn't speak spanish so my whole
family's just talking to chris and i'm
like what the [ __ ] are you guys saying
someone teach me and nobody ever taught
me yeah so when i went to mexico i
realized
mexicans are [ __ ] racist all right
that's all i'm gonna say some of these
[ __ ] are racist as hell if you
do not speak spanish they might as well
just spit on you and you're so really
funny because that's not even your
native language right like that's not
your native tongue that is the other
that's born here but that's not their
native language either so for them to
look down on you
it's the same thing as here like english
is not the
native language of the land it's the
indigenous people's name right and so
mexico is no different neither is puerto
rico like even though they scoff at you
for not speaking that that's your
colonizer's language your native
languages are the languages of the
indigenous people of mexico that's a
native language
not they have that take on it yet yeah i
haven't i haven't at all because my
grandpa's born in the jungle no it's so
straight up the [ __ ] jungle
of course and those are the people that
we look down on but those are the
glorious people of our past have been
able to hold on to our cultural stuff
that
i agree with you 100 my grandpa has not
let anything go since he was five years
old he is the same man since he was a
child and he brings everything with him
it's just because that's that's how you
got your culture lives on your family's
culture it's cultural experience lives
on it's through
folklore and telling us it's not in the
history books the history of books is
like mexicans puerto ricans you know
whereas within
you know if you meet somebody from
chihuahua that they're so different than
someone that is from you know
mexico city it's a trip you know what
i'm saying it's just like everybody has
their own little there's all these
different cultural experiences within
that and for somebody to just paint it
as of this
easier i think
it's easier to go another [ __ ]
mexican they're brown when you're
talking about spanish
yeah it's easier i think
i think a lot of people do it just
because they don't know either of course
i mean who taught us that stuff
we learned all the basic [ __ ] you know
everybody learned the same
basic [ __ ] that is what they thought
i'm just thinking about who's
documenting history now like what are
they gonna say
you know i think he's doing a better job
a hundred years from now there's a lot
more people i feel that want to get it
right yeah but the thing is that like
it's everything is so polarized so that
that donald trump will be an idiot in
some history books and then in some
history books he'll be a hero
you know what i mean i mean depending on
what restaurant you walk in right yeah
who's gonna document his everything's so
polarized everybody has a take everybody
is uh you know
all they do is talk about how they see
something and
what's the facts like is donald trump an
idiot or is he a hero like it depends on
who you're asking
i mean that guy's a [ __ ]
but in a funny way because he's like a
movie character like really you've never
seen idiots of course president camacho
thank you thank you
yes idiocracy that's exactly what
happened to us
a reality star became the president
nobody's drinking water anymore
yeah it's just tricky gatorades and [ __ ]
i love that movie so much thank you no
one ever [ __ ] sees that movie i don't
know oh yeah so you grew up in miami
where at what point did you live in new
york i lived in new york um my mom moved
to new york when i was a kid um
and my grandmother kidnapped me from my
mom she took me from my mother because
my mother was on the run with uh wait
stop your grandma kidnapped you but in a
positive way yeah she did
what's that called there should be a
name for you yeah it's just what is that
saved
that's what saves me it's called
kidnapped though
but you know it's funny she my mom
couldn't say anything because she was on
the run because her man was uh wanted
for murder
so she's in america yeah in new york so
my grandmother got away with it because
oh she was gonna say [ __ ] she can't she
couldn't so your mom just said uh
no go ahead no she didn't know she uh
she came out she came back one day and i
was gone but she couldn't call the
police she couldn't find you or nothing
well she knew where i was you know she
knew that i was with my grandmother but
my grandmother illegally took me she cut
my hair off and took me across state
lines because she flew me
and um it was weird
i was like uh i was a bit i don't know
i was talking to dr drew today and i was
like that where we're unpacking my
trauma so i would say somewhere between
the age of four and six so you remember
this i remember i remember parts of it
some of it i don't remember oh what is
that like there's pictures though and me
with my hair cut off how did she how did
she take you did she have to plan it out
again
or something yeah no i wasn't in school
because my mom was on the run so i was
um
i was with a babysitter and that my
grandmother started doing research she
planned it out she came and got me
changed my clothes
ran to the airport took me to miami
the my uncle was waiting in the car my
with my grandfather and that i remember
parts of it and that was it wow whoa
your grandma is very down
my grandma wouldn't done that [ __ ] she
would have called somebody to help
your grandma's down so
i'm assuming this is good though if
you're on the run with a guy that killed
somebody no yeah no no for sure but
still traumatic because i wanted to be
with my mom of course of course but in
her eyes you need to get out of the
situation yeah no absolutely so did he
ever get caught yeah he did he get
caught he went he got caught my mom came
home he went to jail
and um yeah my mother came home how long
after it um i think it was almost a year
before she oh wow okay okay it wasn't a
really long time but it felt like
forever so it's not like they were
i hate your mom hated her mom for taking
you no she was upset but um
she was angry but you know she had to
come home anyway because when the killer
got caught she had to come
home she didn't get arrested
how's your relationship with your mom
i'm cool i love my mom yeah she's cool
yeah she ended up stabbing him because
he beat her up sorry the way you sit she
stabbed him with a nice pick
uh joe pesci style stabbed him with an
ice pick yeah he cheated on her and he
beat her he beat her and and left her in
central park
uh for dead and so she got went and got
an ice pick and she stabbed him and
i don't know the statue of limitations
uh yeah it's been a while he's dead now
anyway but yeah um
she uh yeah she and that wasn't your dad
that was your mom's just
wow
my mom's wow this this is crazy i didn't
know other stuff happens to kids like
that's insane that sounds like a movie i
know
truly so you went back to miami yeah did
you go back to school yeah i went to
school and i had normalcy and i was
angry and rebellious and mad at my
grandmother for you know trying to give
me a normal life i wanted to be on the
run with my mom
are you an only child no i have uh two
brothers and a sister so did your
grandma take them too no i was it was me
at the time it was just me oh you're the
oldest chick
oh my god could you imagine all the
other kids
oh my god
okay so you grew up in miami how was
this i mean
when did you move from there i left
miami um when i went away to school i
went to florida state um i left miami
oh so you stayed in florida your whole
life no i left i lost four states in
florida it's in tallahassee but i was
there and then i left there and uh i
forgot what year was but i moved to san
diego i got i moved um with my ex who
played football and he went to play for
the chargers oh no [ __ ] yeah
legitimately play for the chargers
that's great yeah and then i left um and
i went back to miami for a couple of
years and then i came back here when i
left him
and i started a new life here because i
i really liked the west coast when i
came for the first time
um i lived in san diego which
probably probably wasn't my favorite
place to live it was cool it was nice i
liked it there but for work-wise it
wasn't the best place for me to be and
so when i came i would i would visit
here and i fell in love with la
and uh when i came back home i was in
miami for two years and i was like i've
grown this place this is not the place
for me and i moved here and i've been
here ever since what were you doing for
work when you went to san diego
um i wasn't doing anything because i was
married to
my i worked at bank of america that's
not not doing anything but my ex was
playing for the chargers so i was kind
of keeping yourself busy at that point
yeah i was modeling i was working oh
nice yeah i was where i would drive
that's why i would come here because i
had jobs and then oh that's that's why
you like to lay better so you're doing
modeling for just
clothing companies makeup stuff i did
everything i did
yeah i did fashion i love doing runway
but i did also i did a lot of hair
modeling
for some reason i did a lot of hair
stuff and um when i was in san diego
that's what i would do because
it was like a day shoot i would go i
would shoot i would do some catalog
stuff and then i could just come home um
i wasn't able to have like a full-time
modeling career because i was a mom you
know i had oh you okay you had children
with uh your ex has been from charge how
many kids do you have two how old are
they now 29 and 25. oh okay so they're
not little kids anymore at all no we all
grew up together oh wow when did you
have your kids i was young i don't want
to talk about that i don't want to talk
about it yeah my mom had him i think 15.
oh yeah yeah oh yeah that sounds about
right that sounds like my grandmother
had her first child at 13. my mother me
and i my mother my grandmother and i all
my daughter broke the cycle she was the
first one to not have a baby to not have
a baby same hair doesn't have a baby the
first one that didn't do it either wow
yeah my mom was 15 my grandma was 13 or
14. yeah my grandmother was 13. yeah but
that's in the 40s and 50s it was a
different
15 year old 14 year old two-year-old
mother is just normal out there yeah
especially in our cultures like that one
why is that
because i never understood like you can
do lines
you can beat the share of your wife but
if you smoke weed you're a piece of [ __ ]
yeah i don't know what it is you could
beat your wife and then hit the joint
like you hit the joint what do you mean
in that culture and for some reason
at least me my experiences anybody from
mexico like oh you snorted lines oh you
beat your wife uh you're you're a
hard-working man oh you smoke weed you
[ __ ] and then you're kicked out
of the family it's interesting the
stigma that weed has and
[Music]
but for people who also which is really
interesting
pride themselves and being medicinal you
know like you know curanderos like we
they're
always talking about how not all all of
them but many of them about nature's
healing and then look down on because
that's what that's what they did with
weed though that and alcohol it's all
white the prom white supremacy i mean at
the end of the day that made the weed
look like the devil for a show but why
would whites why would them why would
that affect all the people in mexico
well i mean it's global though i mean
white supremacy works because it is a
global
business it's not something that's
regional it works it all works together
in tandem i get that but in terms of
like my grandma thinking weeds the devil
she just heard that from her mom and her
mom from religion though probably right
yeah it has a lot to do with religion
but that means well i mean marijuana is
it was a way to put a lot of people of
color behind bars for sure yeah for sure
i mean there was just a way
to and now that they are able to
capitalize on it like the stigma is now
removed you got these housewives smoking
weed
a lot of people still are in jail that
should be honest life sentences still
yeah i mean you know and it's not just
like
yes disproportionately people of color
but even poor white people like i
remember this young 18 year old white
boy who went to jail
i think it was in in colorado it was one
of the states where your first offense
for drugs you go to jail for life what
yeah that's a law right now that was a
law i don't know if it's still alive i'd
be i'm i'll be lying if i told you if i
knew but there was a i remember this
young 18 year old boy first offense has
some marijuana
life sentence and mom was fighting for
years i don't know if they were able to
get them out yet maybe perhaps but
uh yeah it was there were states where
you got caught with it one time
first offense and you would get a really
hefty hefty sentence that's why a lot of
people are in jail i have a friend in
texas that went to prison i think four
years remember spice
and spice that was legal as soon as they
made it illegal they said well you've
had all of these sales prior and they
gave him
eight years but he ended up doing four
that's traumatic that's crazy it changes
your life forever 100 no coming back
from that in terms of trying to gain
there is coming back for that from that
let me just fix that but it just takes
so
i mean they it just really messes up
people's lives a lot of people aren't
able to come back from that you know
how's not on the path that they work
yeah i have another friend he's about to
do i think only down to two years for
weed in texas
damn you got any free friends no i do i
do a lot of them are only the ones i
have going to prison for weed is just on
my brain because they're both getting
sentenced at the same time no i know i
know that's so odd that's messed up
barbaric like history is not going to be
kind of these people doing this oh dude
it's unfucking like you always say it's
a human right like your dad if you was
able to get weed you almost got arrested
for getting your dad weed when he was
sick that's crazy yeah it's insane we
went to jail like no my dad's dying
yeah [ __ ] your dad that's what they want
to say he's going to [ __ ] him yeah oh
[ __ ]
where's he at yeah it's classism too it
has a lot to do with money and well i
think everything does you know all i
mean of course all of it does but when
it comes to marijuana
you're gonna tell me you think that all
them senators don't smoke there's not
one
every one of them you know they do a
line you know it's just based on the law
of averages the people that you know
like based on the 15 people you know
you're going to tell me you think all
those people
that's why it's so fascinating to me to
see them fight so hard for abortion they
have mistresses their mistresses get
pregnant they fly into the states where
they can have an abortion like such
hypocrisy so many of them that do
edibles that um are trying to take you
know
see the
it's just interesting to me to hear
people who
ride so hard against this stuff because
they usually are the closet ones for
sure and i think it the way it is like
i'm a senator i'm against weed openly in
public
but at night i'm getting high yeah this
guy gave me a million dollars to go
against weed publicly yeah
i see it they're just [ __ ] crooks and
i understand i get why they're doing it
i wouldn't do it in the same position i
know people yeah you would like no i
[ __ ] wouldn't but i get why maybe
they grew up
and not getting any money being a
senator for 35 years i'm like [ __ ] is
this my one chance to get it at least i
could smoke at night and that's another
thing of just looking out for yourself
kind of absolutely so many of them and
you know there are some people who
wouldn't do that that's why we don't
become senders
you know what i'm saying like people
will be like well you know if it was you
no it wouldn't it wouldn't be me because
i i don't have the moral
fiber to be a senator i i think that
that should be somebody who can really
you know and not to say that smoking
weed or not smoking weed is a moral
issue for me it's like i don't i don't
think i have the equipment to do that so
i wouldn't even step into that same here
you know what i'm saying like to be in
public service knowing what's going on
in the world and how messed up it is
right now like i'm just like man these
people are foolish those guys need to
smoke some [ __ ] weeds they are
smoking weed we just don't know we just
don't know all the [ __ ] they had to go
through like i am smoking crazy that
we're still talking about it i know it's
20 21 what the [ __ ] is still an issue
like let's for sure like i don't know
come up with a plan oh man do you
remember
even with clinton when he was like i
didn't inhale was it the dumbest [ __ ] i
ever heard yo
you're a [ __ ] liar
to have to feel like you gotta tell that
lie like and no one saved himself but
who believed that all the christian
people from the south said oh i knew
that good man would not inhale that
jazz [ __ ]
that's probably what happened and i i
told marty all the time
that generation of the old white racist
[ __ ] are about to be gone within the
next 15 years i can't wait for the next
group of old old old people they're
gonna be
people that just like like led zeppelin
and should be cool
oh our generation's gonna be great yeah
yeah anybody under 55 now oh man those
people don't got all the religion you
don't got the racism yes figured it out
in our generation a little bit more well
i look at the the uh gen z kids like i'm
like younger kids right now right yeah
yeah they hang out with everybody you
know like yeah i don't know them all but
i'm saying for the most part you see
they're like they're burning it down
they're like we don't we don't want your
[ __ ] you take that [ __ ] with you
we think people need deserve healthcare
we think people they're really just not
rocking with that old school vibe like
they just vibing on a whole another
level too much information though
you see them and they're like there's a
white one an asian one a black one a you
know a latino a latin next there's a
queer one that they're not tripping on
that you see straight kids hanging out
with queer kids it's not like
oh you know what i mean it's just we can
learn something from them even and we're
always [ __ ] on younger people but
the reality of it is is that they're too
busy trying to survive the world that we
[ __ ] up they don't have time to be
such a good way involved in the [ __ ]
and you know and i'll say we and i'm not
even because i think the generation
behind me really did a lot of the damage
and the damage before them because
we um
are we crack babies
i am definitely an acid baby any crack
crank baby crank baby for sure yeah yeah
i think well i was a heroin kid a heroin
baby um
and i think
my my relatives were on crack
so my
my cousins were yeah my cousins
you know we have young cousins that are
definitely crack babies
i don't think it affects you too much
man i got to be honest all the people i
knew that have drug ass drug addict
parents are pretty [ __ ] cool
they had to survive
so many on so many levels like
i don't i mean you know what's funny is
that that people like associate drug
children
with being poor and coming from the hood
but if you think about like all these
kids whose parents did coke who could
afford the expensive drugs you know what
i mean they come from affluent families
where the moms can buy all the pills and
they can afford the oxy and all that
[ __ ] you don't think of junkie when you
think you know yeah you're at target
dressed you're not a junkie yeah exactly
no you're falling asleep and on and off
yeah you gotta you're crushing it hit a
pedestrian you're willing to sell your
ass for it you'll do whatever anybody on
the street is doing and you get to have
this image of being
skipped under wraps stressed out
yeah it goes to the the rolling stones
the mother's helper song it's they they
say it perfectly
that's exactly what america turned into
and that was a 40 year old song and
that's exactly what's going on right now
a lot of moms just on pills because
they're friends stressed out and let me
get a hook up it's
i think it's the radio too has also
they bleep blunt but they don't bleed
lean anymore
no they say percocet they say all that
crazy [ __ ] that passed
my generation did not [ __ ] with those
pills it's the one right before me is
the pills are the coolest thing in the
world right now i don't get it i've
never been a fan
i just i think my mom's
generation was into all the quaaludes
and stuff and now it's oh a vikings
percocet's clown have you ever tried
them though oh yeah they didn't do
anything to me i tried oxies
drugs don't hit me as hard good for you
that's a great thing because some people
one hit is all it takes no like meth i
smoked it with that's just nasty
you know i grew up in a meth town
crank is disgusting i love cocaine but
that's just dead that's just deadly so i
don't [ __ ] with it don't do drugs um
i just i don't i don't see the fun in
falling i do see the fun of falling
asleep but i don't see the fun of
falling asleep
at the [ __ ] movie theater with your
friends and everyone's nodded off yeah
it's sad i've walked into those rooms
full adults all just passing out with a
cup
i mean do your thing that's cool if
that's what you like but it's just so
[ __ ] up to see it people nodding off
in the daytime it steals your life you
know i grew up i was i grew up around
drug addicts i was raised by them
and i just watched a bunch of potential
just go down the drain a lot of stuff
it's very profitable a lot of people
making a lot of money off of it and
they won't even even touch it you know
what i'm saying biggie told you
don't smoke anything you sell
if it's i mean that's what i always say
about like yeah don't do drink soda
don't do that because the guy that owns
pepsi does not [ __ ] drink pepsi
because he knows like that shit's gonna
kill you
it's the same thing with drugs it is a
drug but it's legally marketed with
[ __ ] kobe and michael jordan and [ __ ]
it's just like you said the classism can
they sell the drug yes they can because
they own the media they can and they do
yeah you ever see uh
mental health pills uh
you see 62 ads for pills in the daytime
because they know who the [ __ ]
watching daytime tv absolutely moms that
are watching the kid going you know i am
[ __ ] stressed out let me buy that
[ __ ]
i'm [ __ ] sad
i don't want this uh birthmark on my
face
you know what i mean it's all kinds of
[ __ ] now it's like oh my left nipple is
not as pretty
i'm gonna put this cream on my titties
it's unbelievable i'm like i don't watch
it i can't watch tv because i'm like
it's like going on instagram you start
thinking maybe i do need to get fillers
you know what i mean it's crazy i'm so
glad that doesn't fit i've never once
saw something you know what i need then
i think it's just because i do
advertising and shingle that was a bad
commercial [ __ ] this commercial i think
maybe that's what it is like to my kids
and my wife like oh gotcha whenever
they're like oh they react to an ad i
got you all i can think of meetings
behind the ad and oh yeah i'm like oh
like we saw a commercial last night with
brad pitt and i'm like rented out some
fool's house they're in here shooting
for the day so one day shoot okay
good to be able to see seven seconds you
can see it that's how i watch porn too
that's why i don't watch porn i'm like
somebody's got a boom for the production
value
so i can't watch porn because there's a
dude like this sweating
yeah i can't i'm like i know there's a
boom i know there's a fan they got
they're gonna have lunch her boyfriend's
right there with his arms crosstalk
yeah like or girlfriend cause she
probably hates men
and it's like weird you know what i'm
saying i just i that's the worst you
know people are like what's wrong with
you i'm like this
it's a set
that's [ __ ] up because that's so true
i never think about that you're all
thinking about the bts of it and [ __ ]
there's some dude borrowing money to
make this [ __ ] movie
oh dude that's [ __ ] great now i'm
just gonna think about that that's funny
um my next question i have i watched
parts of your standup okay i saw you
talking about your step-dad and how you
didn't [ __ ] like the guy
i have a whole different step-dad uh
scenario story but
i saw you say that your stepdad was
[ __ ] racist
and i've never heard of a cuban racist
before
obviously because i've only grown up in
my mind give her a little background on
your step dad maybe um
okay
my grandma's is like a she's polish and
jewish she's like a jewish lady
we didn't practice that [ __ ] we tried it
once i can't do the [ __ ] seven day
stuff it sucks
sorry but it's not for [ __ ] me okay
and um
so my mom and my grandpa's from texas
he's spanish
so my mom looks like a white lady but
she's [ __ ] spanish
and she married
my old stepdad she married him
he just tried a [ __ ] white
supremacist like we went to prison she
we visited him every [ __ ] week
covered in horrible [ __ ] tattoos
but we were visiting him and my sister's
way darker than me so it was a very odd
hand-hold into the prison
and you see this full with [ __ ] all
these crazy tattoos come up and i loved
that guy he was so [ __ ] awesome and
cool and he taught me more than my dad
ever tried to
and he always explained it to me like
racism is inside not outside like inside
you have to
or you're gonna die but outside my best
friend was a black kid and his dad was
our
big buff-ass cop of the town and they
knew each other it was like
you see where i'm going like i don't
speak spanish i'm the brown kid
everybody [ __ ] me already and then this
is my stepdad
[ __ ] like this is not a good look for me
in the mexican town
blue eye [ __ ] blonde hair guy like
this is not good for us
so that was my experience was uh
just being confused
like that that sounds confusing um
you know people in jail and prison the
prison system do have to pick aside
because they they have to survive
um we don't know anything about that
because we uh have the privilege of
being free and um and not to condone or
excuse why people are in prison but they
have to survive in there we don't know
what that's like and it's hell right
yeah because our prison system sucks
we don't rehabilitate criminals we just
multiply them and send them back out
into the journal yeah we teach them how
to perfect you know their art and then
we condemn them and criticize them when
so many criminals who are in washington
and all over the place are not getting
caught for the crimes they're committing
and then
you know poor people and brown people
black people who have to survive out
there trying to do whatever they got to
do to eat because
the system is
set up for them to [ __ ] fail but um
you know my stepfather's cuban
racism lives all over the world in latin
america um you know mexicans can be
racist they they have code words for
black people just like everywhere else
but they also have their own black
people just like everybody else and
you know like uh
you know the people who suffer the most
at the hands of latinx people latinos
latine people is the
very own black people and indigenous
people and asian people that belong to
the latin american countries
uh my stepfather's from cuba
they have they have a very they're very
popular for their brand of racism in
miami i've never heard any of this oh
yeah not all of them i mean just to say
that all cubans are racist is dumb um to
generalize an entire group but um you
know they they have
they do uh support and live by the
tenants of races because
you know whiteness is whiteness and it's
not exclusive to just american people
yeah you know
asian people have issues with racism um
asian people are racist i've never heard
of any of this oh yeah they have asian
people who have racist issues um we see
it in movies like um
funny menace to society there's this
korean and black uh you know
antagonistic relationship which leads to
the death of somebody but that happened
in real life here in south central where
a young black girl was killed by an
asian woman and the woman woman never
went to jail
um it happens a lot in you know
communities of black people where a lot
of our people and different people who
are immigrants come into black
communities and make a living and they
have stores and businesses and they
capitalize off of black business and
then they
turn around and mistreat black people so
that happens all over the world that's
not something that is just exclusive to
europe um you know people in asia
brighten their skin people in india
brighten their skin
to look whiter they you know they they
do uh surgeries on their faces so that
they could look more european it's quite
the mind [ __ ] you know to
to just brainwash people into believing
to focus so much on how being white is
better
you know while the world burns
yeah but then white people are tanning
[ __ ] getting ass shots getting their
lips injected
you know wanting the aesthetic but now i
wanted the reality of what it is to be
black and brown and
it's just it's like um the greatest mind
[ __ ] of all time so you got
you know you got the kardashians getting
ass shots putting the stuff in their
lips you know you got these women
tanning so that they can have some skin
and then you got people who have brown
skin and black skin or brown skin and
darker skin
hating themselves thinking there's
something wrong with that melanin that
they have that white people wish that
they had it's just it's just like it's
the grass is always greener it's a mind
[ __ ]
about my [ __ ] of all times yeah
that was such a good way to put it with
you guys thank you
people just sitting around worrying
about all that [ __ ] and then they have
no health care they ain't got no food in
the house they can't get a job they
can't get a loan they're not getting a
quality education
but
they're like but i'm whiter than you
put dumb ass down somewhere i have uh
little sisters and it's it's weird to me
hearing the [ __ ] they talk about she's
14 and 16.
oh my god
i have a little brother that's 17 on my
mom's side but he's like 27 in his head
so he's very mature he talk he's
thinking like i'm he's thinking like i
am like all right what can i get to do
this my other little sisters are very uh
mtv
girl girl style girls and it's so odd to
me because you know you see this they
still watch mtv no they want to learning
how to get pregnant what that's all the
shows are teen mom now
it's [ __ ] horrible and then just
ridiculousness for 22 hours but he's
he's crushing it i don't know what he
must have bought mtv but rob dear dick
shout out to you that is true though
um
so it is odd seeing like you said the
gen z
seeing what's important seeing what and
either christmas list [ __ ]
i wanted to reach through the phone
freddie cougar and just slap the [ __ ]
out of them their christmas list pissed
me the [ __ ] off was that what was it
looking like fillers
um
uh what was it fillers
my other sister wants liposuction
how old sixteen [ __ ] years old yeah
doesn't go to the gym
or the [ __ ] gym
you're [ __ ] it's crazy but i have two
other cousins that are identical same as
they were born and they all live next to
each other so it's it's just like uh
like you said why i'm whiter than you
it's more of that like well you know
you're fatter than me well [ __ ] now i
need liposuction
it's crazy to see because as a kid i
wasn't i was just [ __ ] poor i wasn't
thinking about any of that [ __ ] yeah me
though so to see people like oh you have
time to think about stuff you want weird
because they're on instagram and
instagram is always pushing
that stuff right instagram tells you you
gotta you know i don't you go to
instagram and i'm like i'm like oh [ __ ]
i'm gonna die like
according to instagram i'm dead cause
you know um i'm i'm i'm in my 40s so i'm
like oh [ __ ] like i'm in my 40s
i uh you know i'm a woman of color like
it's everything is it makes you feel bad
about yourself if you if you allow that
stuff to penetrate so i can only imagine
an underdeveloped mind you feel like
you're not rich enough you're not pretty
enough you're not thin enough you know
all that [ __ ] is like it's constant it's
[ __ ] up it's like having a shitty mom
but on your phone all the time yeah oh
you're too [ __ ] fat no kid's gonna
like you that's like a bad mom in your
phone we just had our awareness of like
what was going on around us growing up
that's why i was oh yeah anything in
your reach and you could ride your bike
and that's all the problems i had we
were surviving too like in our minds we
were surviving because if i grew up poor
so i was like
every day i made it home or i made it to
school was an accomplishment without
getting raped without getting kidnapped
without getting beat up without getting
you know
[Music]
shots
without getting shot at without getting
stabbed like it was just oh
you know what i mean and these kids like
got the luxury of sitting at home
watching dr jung money on instagram re
reconstruct people's bodies and never
seen that yes he's a plastic surgeon in
houston and like he just restructures
people's i mean [ __ ] i called and asked
for a consultation that was like j these
are all the drake's [ __ ] go here i
was like hey let me go up but it's
it's so interesting because you start
watching that stuff and it starts
consuming you oh i've never seen that i
uh
we i know a girl that recently she's a
model chick but
she's got her [ __ ] bottom two ribs
removed yeah so the hard waist could be
real
back in the day i think that was a rumor
but these girls are really doing it all
right yeah they said that about janet
jackson they said it about cher but they
really are removing ribs so you can get
the hourglass shape it looks like a
cartoon or those old toys like the
street sharks they're just hard
like they don't move that's what people
look like right now that stuff is more
normal now like having a dog yeah like
show up and give you ivs in your house
you're a doctor like things are just
more normal i feel like yeah they have
normal lives but you know
it's it's sad because ribs are designed
to protect your organs they're there for
a reason yeah you know like booms
put them there so that you know what i'm
saying it's just like
you
when it got those removed so that you
could look smaller
it's just crazy and you know like and
the thing is that it's not resolving
what the issue is because the issue
really is an internal issue right
it's how you feel about yourself
and that kind of stuff is just a
band-aid but it's just it's just like
don't get in a fight
or a car accident yeah they gonna [ __ ]
you up girl for real no it's crazy
seeing people remove bones right now or
i know rosie's her some of her friends
do the bbl [ __ ] oh yeah that's the baby
oh my god you can't move around for
months for did you know that for months
you have to be
like this what if someone beats your ass
you gotta sleep on your stomach that's
crazy it's like you're pregnant you
gotta sleep on your stomach because you
can't mess the shape of your boob isn't
that crazy you're molding your body like
clay
it's [ __ ] unreal i think it's funny i
don't know anything about that yeah it's
disgusting it's disgusting um
so i have a question for you
i watched one
like
episode
youtube
do a better job is it a clip or like
sometimes like is the clip for the
[ __ ] whole episode because it's a 60
minute clip i watch the young turks that
is a show that you that you're like i
said earlier we're politically
illiterate i haven't
i watched and i went [ __ ] what's going
on
because like i i i love that you're
honest about always i have to be but let
me tell you most people
don't
they just think they do oh yeah because
they're getting their information
scrolling
and and in little tidbits i don't know
like i am not as politically astute as i
would like to be
i just i just have an idea about what i
think about
uh when it comes to the world and i
apply what i think i think
that we should stop being so [ __ ]
greedy
and and that maybe we should share some
things
some people will call me a communist for
that i am not a communist
we live in a socialist country where the
socialism only benefits the top one
percent right because we have a post
office we have a lot of programs that
are social programs but they benefit
rich people
i would like to see those programs
benefit people who are not rich because
they need it more right so we
we uh
pay taxes that you know support the
lifestyles of the people who are our
public servants and they live better
lives than us and their children live
better lives than us and go to better
schools than us and i think that's
[ __ ] up yeah but that does not mean i
want to make america cuba right or
russia or china it just means that i
think that this system is [ __ ] up and
it is really hurting the people who we
saw during the pandemic are the ones
that show up and do the bulk of the work
that many people benefit uh from and
then all of a sudden we're calling them
essential workers but now that covet is
wearing off we're going back to treating
people like [ __ ] and i have a problem
with that so when they put me in on
these platforms
that's what i'm speaking to do i know
what laws were passed last year do i
know what the
you know what's on the table the bills
do i know you know can i talk to you
about the the bill spending
the spending power of america within it
when it comes to
arms i have an idea about it but do i
have the intricate
know the intricacies of that stuff
absolutely not and i think that most
people don't
and that they are just spewing talking
points that their favorite people
are giving them
and
you know like for example we talk about
this vaccination
i don't care if you get vaccinated or
not that's your business i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna lose sleep telling people
to go get vaccinated
what i will tell you is that a lot of
people who follow the people who are
they say are anti-vaxx
are vaccinated
donald trump's entire family is
vaccinated
you know uh
everybody at fox news is vaccinated
everybody at cnn is vaccinated because
they have to be vaccinated to work at
those places and those people got
vaccinated because they don't want to
lose the bag yeah right so
my problem is you're telling people or
encouraging people to speak out against
vaccinations
because
you want those people to stay with you
because you know that that's what
they're passionate about because you're
stoking their fears
and you're gonna make money off of those
people supporting you but you don't give
a damn about those people
and that's what i have a problem with if
you were honest about that right
i am not going to tell people what to do
with their bodies i'm not going to
ridicule people who don't get vaccinated
i'm not going gonna try to shame anybody
that is not my job
what i will say is
that a lot of the people who are
encouraging people not to get vaccinated
are secretly vaccinated
and some of them not they they they
don't feel like they they don't have to
hide it anymore they feel you're so dumb
they can tell you i got vaccinated but
i'm a fight to the death for you not to
get vaccinated
why if you really feel that way why why
not be honest about why you got
vaccinated tell the truth about why you
got vaccinated you know what i'm saying
and they don't but that's just one of
the issues and i don't want to get all
into that because i know people this is
polarizing the country people are
marching they're having fights over this
are they what
i don't watch the [ __ ] news i didn't
know people were cared about the
vaccination like that oh no people are
vaccinated get fighting they're marching
they're saying my body it's it's funny
because it's people who are
anti-abortion
anti-women saying my body my choice now
walking around with signs saying my body
my choice oh [ __ ] the irony of it all
right and it's just interesting to me so
for me it's like
all i want
at the end of the day what i push for
the most above all things is a better
education for americans
that we have access to information
because information is power and so i
think that because we are we our
education system is so poor and our
people are so dumb in this country
anybody can come along and tell you a
story and [ __ ] with you emotionally and
drive you
to a cliff and you will be willing to
jump off and that's what you're seeing
happening
in this country from everybody not just
right wingers uh [ __ ] the people that
are leftists are doing the same [ __ ]
they're like oh there's a market here
that's real like i said that's really
what it comes down to can i make money
off these [ __ ] well now they
buy shirts
get real deep into jesus because they
realize they're into that they're gonna
come to
they come to your events you know what
i'm saying they come to your they pay to
see you speak they buy your shirts they
pay for your patreons
and you are just filling them with the
information that is reinforcing their
fears and their hate and their hate
usually comes from their fears so now
they're telling you the immigrants are
coming to get your stuff they're going
to take your jobs that's the only [ __ ]
well it's a bunch of [ __ ]
there's a bunch of jobs available right
now right [ __ ] mcdonald's are
short-handed yeah
you know a lot of these uh and then
they're people who
you know you we live in california up
there in merced you saw all those signs
that were like farmers for trump
right shitload of them right then they
deported the immigrants because they
participated in the raids
and then those signs turned to
we are we have a shortage and
we we don't have food where are the
white people who said that immigrants
were taking their jobs they're not going
to pick the strawberries and ought to
end no brad has ever picked the grapes
in life they're not going to do not
going to [ __ ] happen so the reality
of it is it's just all a mind [ __ ]
and that's why you got to get high
so one big commercial for marijuana nice
oh my god i love that
okay so that you can survive this whole
reality of [ __ ] of people who are
constantly when you sit down you sit
these people people down and you you
give them information and they'll be
like what am i doing when i started
smoking weed when i was like 18 it
really there was a sense of that like
god this
it's [ __ ] [ __ ] it's
what the [ __ ] like who do you trust if
you can't trust the people that are
supposed to we could be so advanced we
didn't even have a plan for a [ __ ]
pandemic like i know that's what
astonished me was we didn't even have
crazy
just paper signs on restaurants we had
[ __ ] nothing because we're so cocky
we think that it's not gonna happen to
us we think we're [ __ ] too cool yeah
we said this last episode americas
thinks they're so [ __ ] cool
that we'll we'll get by like the [ __ ]
ferris bueller movie like it's
going to make it home before our parents
get there like what the [ __ ] you're
thinking and no we didn't as a kid like
the way you thought about america you
would have thought i thought a bunch of
whole coconuts snap into action
and [ __ ]
we got something for that like of course
we do you know it seems so obvious but
we could be so we could be so modern the
fact that we're still talking about the
[ __ ] from [ __ ] 50 years ago is insane
and that's why these young people are
like we hate y'all and we can't wait for
y'all to die
you know what i mean like to these older
people and then people get really
offended people are fighting for you see
these old white racist men
holding on fighting for they need
something but for what though i'm saying
that's what they think i need something
because these kids can all beat my
[ __ ] ass my son's boss is black my
[ __ ] gardener is more has more money
than me because he landscapes the whole
town
and now it's like
and my wife wants to smash him
exactly my wife stares at the young
mexican kids blowing my lawn how many
more generations until like religion
isn't even one
round
20-year thing
and i think 20 more years many more i
mean because think of it the middle of
america
i always i only see [ __ ] the coasts
on tv
no one ever does the movie about the kid
in iowa
but you know it's funny though like
i was
i saw that the island of tonga just got
their first case of kovit right that was
just in the last first day
i think it was tonga i'm not sure it was
one of the polynesia islands
and it was a missionary coming from
from uh new zealand and i'm like you
[ __ ] up i'll be down be pissed
bring in the word and [ __ ] bring the
word and the disease on a seven day
lockdown
um
because of cobin they had their first
documented case of covet so they gotta
wait for seven days the whole [ __ ]
place for everyone out there doesn't
know what tong and who tongan people are
the way i like to explain it telling
people where the guys at samoans go [ __ ]
i don't want to fight that dude
for real because my fiance her family's
tongue in town oh one of the best music
groups of all times the jets if you
don't know who they are you don't know
who they're just how did you know
i've never seen you not know something i
found out
my mom didn't put me on to that
how old are you 32. but my mom put me on
to so much she was both old school i
know
i mean that's that's 80s now my sister's
on [ __ ] watching so you [ __ ] idiot
my sister's music
expansion of brain just keeps going for
my i don't
know it's 80s i think they're the 80s
and maybe 90. all the real 80s stuff was
like for me was like stevie b and lisa
lisa's type of stuff that was during
that time so maybe i have to hear the
song yeah they had a song um
crush on you was one of the big songs
make it real like i know what you're
saying i know what song that is sorry
now i just heard the song in my head
that's like the big 80s
uh hairspray dance party [ __ ] mm-hmm
yeah i love that stuff that they're
tongan i didn't know that
yeah yeah so that that's that's the way
they're like a family group with 62
cousins
dude simones and tongas have so many
[ __ ] family members it's crazy i love
my polynesian brothers it's crazy
my fiance's best friend her her
husband's they're all from some uh
samoan island what does he call it
samoa he always says it all [ __ ] up oh
you're americans
don't putting that spin on it i always
talk [ __ ] to him but yeah his whole
family he's the smallest one and he's
like six two monster everybody's six
nine
and those guys that's
the nfl will soon be samoan and tongan
polynesian i guarantee you the nfl is
gonna be all islanders soon
with my uh when my ex played um football
for the chargers like my crew
mat shout out to mary salsa i hope she's
listening to this but i used to hang out
with these um
samoan uh samoan people that uh whose or
wives whose husbands played on the team
they were just the coolest people
because uh you know like there was like
um this culture of people who would go
to the football games like dressed up
you know um with heels and you know made
up like you see on those on the
housewives shows and uh and then
the the samoan wives would have on their
jerseys with some chucks and some jeans
they would bring food that's mexicans in
california yeah we just had a live show
like that we just we were just like
it's a game we sitting at the stadium
but they were my i used to just love you
know kicking it with
um with them they were they they
embraced me and my son and they were
really good to me and my daughter
because my daughter came right after
what's up guys special shout out to one
of our sponsors this is on it on it is
dedicated to bringing peak optimal
performance the highest level of
performance you can get out of your body
on it is here to give you all the tools
you need so before we keep going guys do
me a favor go to onit.com or if you want
it's linked in the description of every
single video or it's linked in the
pinned comments on youtube so onnit dot
com forward slash yolo that's our
discount code from the podcast that's 10
off of every single thing in the store
except the weights alpha brain shroom
tech with whey proteins whatever you
guys want that's 10 off and you're
helping support the podcast and you guys
already know alpha brain is the first
thing i ever tried from on it and it's
the main thing that i use so if you've
gotten stuff from on it before you know
the alpha brain that little black bottle
of pills that [ __ ] works wonders so guys
it has now evolved it's also alpha brain
shots all right i'm just gonna say i
haven't tried them yet but the packaging
and the look is dope so if you're like
me i'm not a morning person all right i
am not a morning person i wish that i
was but alpha brain does help me out
it's like the extra boost in the morning
it is the wake up call so if any of this
has piqued your interest at all if this
is a wake-up call for you to get started
or maybe you just want to see if it
works or see if it helps you go to
onit.com that's o-n-n-i-t dot com
forward slash yola and that's 10 off of
everything i just talked about like i
said except the weights so once again
guys thank you so much for supporting on
it thank you for clicking the links
thank you for buying stuff thank you for
supporting the brands that support us
what do your kids do now
so my son is um a writer director oh
[ __ ] and my my daughter's a writer my
daughter um dude really yeah they both
are creatives
they're both really smart people but
they're both very well not but but and
they're very creative
nice what do they do what like writing
for themselves for shows what are they
so my daughter works on uh works in a
writer's room for a tv show um that's on
now and then my son is
he's a he's working on a movie uh a
horror film his first horror film but he
he shoots a lot of movies independent
stuff he's um
you know he edits for um
he's worked with tiffany hottis she does
some stuff with her he works with um
edited some comedy specials but his his
thing is directing no [ __ ]
that's cool well before i met mario
that's what he does he's the comedy
circuit he does like he
explain what you do i always say it
[ __ ] up
uh a lot of the tour stuff related with
the comics targeted advertising graphics
apparel working with the agents the
venues all that kind of stuff so
basically the manager not so much now
that the podcast is getting so big i had
like probably nine or ten comics i was
working with and now it's like three or
four
but
this is really becoming my priority oh
nice that's good that the podcast i quit
my podcast oh you stopped doing it yeah
it was too heavy no it was more of the
content stuff like every conversation
became like a political or racial
conversation
every single one like i could have
somebody come on and talk about grapes
and then it would turn into
you know white people ruined grapes for
everybody and i was like yeah they did
and then and then we just and
and it was um white grapes come about
now what the [ __ ]
yeah
but it just got so heavy for me that i
was i couldn't um
i couldn't unwind from it every
conversation edge all the time it was
affecting my comedy because i was like
um i still have to go out and do comedy
and then i was just so hyper focused on
injustice
that it just it made me depressed i
started thinking about how [ __ ] up the
world was because all i was watching was
videos about injustices and [ __ ] will
ruin your day it made me depressed yeah
i was in a no legit depression like i
was just sitting around like thinking
what's it all for like all this [ __ ] is
[ __ ] up the world is terrible what am
i doing why am i here like it was
and i had to step away from it because i
was just like oh i don't want to walk
around filled with hate i just don't i
want to [ __ ]
walk around being filled with solution
like you know like what we gonna do you
know how we're gonna fix this what we're
going to do to make and now you're corny
for that right so now if you say stuff
like that you're corny right because
well i mean only people saying corny
[ __ ] are the ones that are going to get
up and do [ __ ] anyway facts yeah [ __ ]
them i always say the armchair activist
kids kids that are sitting in their
house going well you should be marching
while they're eating something yeah get
the [ __ ] out of here yeah dude a lot of
people go out because we have a big
following and a lot of people why aren't
you speaking about this because i don't
[ __ ] care
like i truly don't want to get into this
i don't it's not on my brain this show
is quite the opposite it is describe
your podcast as we're live it's the
[ __ ] yeah we we very
like i said uh politically illiterate
i i'm i'm be honest with everything most
people are though like that even when
you hear people talk like oh my goodness
the whole
what about benghazi and the emails it's
just it's a that was hillary clinton and
that was you know the thing about the
emails on her server the personal emails
the scandal and benghazi or
whatever it is people just hang on to
whatever little bit of information
and whatever spin they got on that and
they don't but those are their talking
points you know what i'm saying and it's
like i think
unless you're super educated i feel like
we all are guilty of it in a little bit
until we check ourselves and go shut the
[ __ ] up you don't even know what's going
that's why i like to say it now like i
don't know what's going on tell me but
that's great though but even the super
educated people like people who go to
school forever
they're the ones that are just walking
around telling everybody that's wrong
you shouldn't do that i got this
information so it makes people who don't
have the benefit of that type of
education say i [ __ ] hate you you
intellectual elitist you're smug you're
a [ __ ] [ __ ] and then they're
they're like you're dumb you're ignorant
you're stupid look at you you don't have
an education divided and that's there's
there we go and then we have this war
and none of it is solving anything
you know what i'm saying not one because
you can read all the books in the world
if you've never been you could read all
the books about struggle in the world
but if you've never been in the hood
in a poor place and you've never
experienced poverty and you don't know
what the reality of it is of people who
are have a foot on their necks and
they're every day are trying to figure
out the next day what the hell
intellectual take can you take on that
situation
true just the technical term nothing
else past that so it's like why why do
you think these people want to hear you
you got all these tv shows [ __ ]
wake up every morning to sit around the
table and tell people how to think while
they're being driven to their jobs have
five thousand dollar handbags walking
around with dogs that they created
because they thought they looked cool
you know kids go to the best schools got
on the nicest clothes
telling [ __ ] that make towels
for a living how they supposed to
this is how you're supposed to see life
let me speak for you no wonder there is
this war you know people are tired poor
people
working class people they [ __ ] tired
it's a really good way to put that yeah
yeah that was a good way of putting that
because
i
for every ounce in me when i have kids i
want them to be those kids like no no i
want to spoil the [ __ ] don't be a
piece of [ __ ] but because that's what i
lacked my whole life just growing poor
as [ __ ] so it's like no no i want to be
driven to my [ __ ] because you know what
i never got i took the bus or walked my
whole life
because we're [ __ ] broke and you got
lunch tickets if you got lunch tickets
like or you just wait you need a home
type [ __ ] i'm sure it's the same thing
with marty like
there's just uh
like you said
it's just so
how the [ __ ] can you say any of this and
you've never experienced anything like
you said you can read everything about
a struggle but if you've never literally
went [ __ ] i have no food or money till
friday [ __ ]
i got to figure it out
that's
real yeah just like people who don't
have homes you know i i was uh i was
without a home
and i i know i lit i mean i there was a
period of time that i lived in best
westerns right and
oh no [ __ ] yeah younger no no just not
as a kid it was when i lived here and
people will sit down and have a
conversation and an argument about what
the proper terminology is to call
somebody who doesn't have a home
it's unhoused we don't stay homeless
and i'm like [ __ ] are you focusing on
how to get these [ __ ] in the
house
and a place to live it's not getting
offensive yeah get the mental health
care get some help get some help with
addiction we i talked about that today
earlier like we we have a conversation
it's so easy to just say oh i'm here on
behalf of these people what the hell are
you doing to help them other than
focusing on terminology yeah words
you ain't gonna never change the way
people talk some people don't always
talk the way that they talk i went to
school
for uh english i went to florida state i
was an english major i had all a's and
b's and all of my classes in my major
and some days my subject and subjects
and verbs don't agree that's just the
way i talk i'm pretty lazy i got a hood
speak to me that i've had my whole life
you think you gonna change me cause you
tweet me [ __ ] if you don't sit your ass
down somewhere that's why people hate
you
that's how i feel right now i love this
so much it's exactly how i feel every
day and people get so mad i go then turn
your [ __ ] phone off
you can follow my [ __ ] right now or keep
bitching because i don't give a [ __ ]
about it i love this
thank you i like how you guys say yes
you'd be offended if you understood how
much i don't give a [ __ ] oh yeah that's
one that's my go-to i love that line i'm
offended if you knew
how much i don't give a [ __ ] about oh my
god i'm gonna have to quote that [ __ ]
please tweet that so i can retweet it
it's true though it's true it's true i
think that's when like i said earlier
you don't watch them you don't know
about the riots like
i watched the office yesterday and i
edited all day i have no idea what's
going on on earth i see twitter [ __ ]
and i know it's an ignorant take but
it's like
can i help
i can't why the [ __ ] do i want to stress
myself out about this all day seeing
somebody else get shot in the back
it really [ __ ] it
video i know it's just videos instagram
you can turn it off but one little video
of seeing somebody get shot while
they're handcuffed it's like stay with
you forever i can't stop thinking about
it yeah it's [ __ ] my whole day up and
i know a lot of people like well he's
dead you just have to think about it
like
i can't help or change it the way you
help though is this how this is how you
help you think about
investigate you research
who is who are the local politicians in
your town right that's the most
effective way we focus so much on the
presidential election
but the people in your town who's the
superintendent at the school
where your kids go to school what does
that person think about mexicans and
black people right you can see their
track record by the things that they are
voting for and the things that they're
trying to get implemented in your
community and you don't vote for that
person and you get that person the [ __ ]
out of there
those are the little things that you can
do if you know you go to a business and
they don't treat mexicans well they
don't treat plaque people well walk an
extra block and go to another store and
don't put your dollars but that's how
you help right tweeting
sure tweeting can be effective social
media has been effective in doing some
things and um amplifying some things
that needed to be amplified bringing the
light
but
some people don't effect it [ __ ] with
your psyche so the best way to help
uh black people in this country is not
just by sharing videos which is trauma
porn to watch black people getting
killed all the time or mexicans getting
killed who also get killed by the cops
latinos get killed by the cops too
sometimes the way that you show up in
the world is by participating in things
that help get these [ __ ] out of
there as opposed to thinking that just
because you shared a tweet or you threw
up a black square on instagram
that you did some major [ __ ] to help
black people in this country that's not
helping black people get equity and
justice in this country it's not helping
immigrants not get raped by these
officers at the border it's not helping
you know kids who are being molested by
their teachers at the school because
they're not being properly
you know um
vetted there's so much stuff you can do
locally and you ain't gonna tell nobody
you ain't gotta tweet about it you ain't
got an instagram about it as long as you
know what you're doing who gives a [ __ ]
what you're gonna get some likes nobody
cares nobody cares
no one gives a [ __ ] no and everybody
cares about their own likes
and they only give it to you as a
courtesy because they want to get your
attention so you can give it back to
them
that's what we've gotten to
perfect
couldn't have said it any better that's
exactly what's going on so you're the
first person that's out of all the
people getting pissed off at me and all
this [ __ ] you're the first person to
ever explain what you can actually go do
and help because that is within your own
reach it's not like oh i can't talk to
the president and i can talk to my local
school attendant or my local police
chief or
that is something that you can actually
do yeah you have to see like you know
you know who is who voted to who helped
um
voted against the sanctuary
cities and who didn't want to help these
you know undocumented people that came
here from mexico el salvador honduras
guatemala seeking
refuge because they didn't want to get
killed they don't want to get raped
because that's happening in these
countries because we destabilize
destabilized their governments and
[ __ ] up these people's countries and
then now we want to complain when they
come here but the the reality of it is
is like you finding out those things
will make
the world a better place for youtube
because you don't want
a superintendent at a school
that is a shitty person right so you got
rid of that shitty person they did it in
florida the people who
you know were someone that was in office
during george zimmerman getting off or
killing trayvon martin wait he didn't go
to jail no he didn't go to jail he got
i'm so [ __ ] late man oh my god i
thought that man was in prison no that
man has been harassing um and mocking
black people on twitter and selling
pictures and you know of trayvon
that's that's that's the question of the
hour oh all these gangsters talking [ __ ]
no one's popped this [ __ ] dude but
then sorry i'm not saying go kill the
man i'm sorry no i mean but everybody is
like in all of this
but um
they voted that d.a out of there they
got that person out of there that's how
you make a change and that way you don't
feel overwhelmed because you feel like
you have a sense of accomplishment and
you get
you feel like there's hope because
people in our communities need hope
and so
i'm not gonna argue with somebody and
tell them that they're shitty
oh you why are you not reading the news
you should know what's going on
most of us don't know what's going on
anyway if you're reading it on the
internet it probably isn't 100
accurate because the powers that be
ain't giving us the information that we
need that's how they keep us where we
are they live it's a perfect example
that the world is they live have you
ever seen this yes that's how i see the
world of all times like oh no no and
truman showed like you're learning too
much tip that [ __ ] boat over yeah
that's how i feel with everything that's
it's like don't rock the boat [ __ ]
cause they're gonna tip it over on you
and that makes you a conspiracy theorist
right but the reality of it is it's not
it's like true you know we get
information now because of the internet
and there are people who
leak information and we have the the
people who you know tell
um
it's
it's we got access to things that we
shouldn't but they do tip the boat of
course they tip the boat you think that
that's the thing and so
the only way to maintain a sense of hope
is just to focus on what's around you
and what you can control
because you're not going to change
donald trump
you're not going to change joe biden
you're not going to change kamala harris
then they playing a whole different game
and they all in the same game y'all can
fall for that [ __ ] all y'all want to
a lot of [ __ ] in the same game
they in the bag game how do i get money
back there's no no politicians should
have a hundred mil
no that's [ __ ] up or be a celebrity i
feel like that's that's what we're doing
because because for me
i wasn't around but [ __ ] ronald
reagan was a cowboy and i didn't know
that until i was about 10. president of
sag
he was the president of the acting [ __ ]
yeah
he was the president of sag the screen
actors guild they picked the right
[ __ ] to play the the
religious politician man because he
played that part well yeah had his wife
telling kids saying all the drugs while
they was dropping them off in the hood
and getting crack all over this yeah we
just had rick ross on here uh uh freeway
ricky and he explained that [ __ ]
to the t it's so sad what happened to
that man he gets played in every [ __ ]
everything he's ever done he's gotten
[ __ ]
and one day he won't but
when he was talking about the drug and
the nicaragua and the contra [ __ ] it's
sounds like a
movie that really happened they did a
movie about it i know but it's because
it was so unreal that they had to make a
movie about it
and i feel like how is that not talked
about more now
and people who trust the government now
but in the 80s they were [ __ ] you
over and killing your kids
getting them hooked on trucks
yeah and this is not an anti-government
podcast but i'm not with that that
sounds like [ __ ]
i mean the thing is it's like
the thing about this whole
anti-government thing is that
you're if this is supposed to be america
and you're supposed to be able to have
these certain unalienable rights you
should be able to question this
government all of it not just the one
the the side that you don't
you know who's uh beliefs don't line up
with yours all of it you should be
questioning your government that's what
being that's what americans can do that
people in other countries cannot do yeah
you know what i'm saying that's what's
supposed to be being patriotic is not
pledging your undying and unquestioning
allegiance to america is saying
hey i want you to be the best that you
can be
and this [ __ ] right here is questionable
and i need to know what's happening here
you're supposed to be able to do that
that's what being an american is
and for some reason
it's been changed this whole idea about
questioning the government being
unpatriotic
is part of the the thing that they
trickle down to us so that we can start
believing that [ __ ] that keeps us
ignorant and [ __ ]
wow these [ __ ] are rich they
bawling that's what they want though
it's to keep like yo watch some sports i
just took away half your rights and your
money yeah well i mean like i said you
keep reverting back to the movie they
live it's they live to keep a
distraction while they run [ __ ] world
that's what it is
i mean
like you said you can't do anything
about it but start local if you start
local then you can have a domino effect
if everybody in their community starts
doing if everybody takes over their
village and says this is my village i'm
a protected i'm going to do everything
and everybody who's in this [ __ ]
has to be part of the pro the solution
and how we're gonna and that starts
bleeding that's how you make a change
and then you get that trash out of there
you're not you know you think that
because you voted for biden or you voted
for trump that you made a big difference
in the world
oh you poor souls that you really
believe that [ __ ] it's so funny like
these [ __ ] it's so you know
i've been all over the world and even
politicians that you think hate each
other we're friends
they do it for
you to fight and then they go have
dinner yeah exactly
and then they go hang out with each
other because they get rich because war
is profitable it truly is it very much
is people
nothing's going to get so deep but you
can look up who owns these manufacturing
companies
you're going to be pissed when you
realize the same people starting these
wars are the ones that have stock in
these companies of course and i get it
it's a money thing that's a smart
business play but damn they don't even
get in trouble don't even go to jail
is that even in the news because they
own the [ __ ] news outlet they don't
even get in trouble truman show
smoke some weed smoke some weed there we
go um
so before we go i want to ask you about
your special it's coming out you said
november 4th on hbo max yes hbo max
november 4th what's it called fighting
words
seems perfect ah yeah
so um what special is this how many have
you done so this is my first uh hour
special oh really yeah
um and it's
you know on it's about 40 something
minutes of material i actually recorded
over an hour but um some of the stuff
was cut
uh
because that's the world we live in now
but there's a documentary at the end who
was filmed by this award-winning
documentarian and i'm very proud of it
that has to do with me visiting my
father
since i was a little kid i haven't seen
him going to the dominican republic and
puerto rico
and uh there's this just a documentary
at the end that's like a bonus to the
special
um but it's called fighting words and
you know um
it's layered uh there are a lot of
things in there that a lot of nuance a
lot of things that i wanted to explore
some people are going to be mad at me
that's why i called it fighting words
but um
you'd be offended if you knew how much i
don't give a [ __ ]
about what you think about me
love it that's how i feel i'm so glad
those are the best words ever
[Laughter]
it's so true though and it makes you
feel like
i won today [ __ ] you guys yeah it's true
so they made you cut out some stuff
or you felt you needed to cut some stuff
out um i would say that nobody made me
do anything
i'm gonna be fair but there were just
decisions that were made about um you
know some of the terminology some of the
things i'm imperfect i don't ever
pretend to say to think
i don't pretend that i know it all
because i don't and i [ __ ] up and i i'm
still learning and i'ma continue to
learn and i'm always being perfect
because i don't know anybody who is
but it's just a lot of pressure on
comedians right now um and not to say
that poor the poor comedians you know
they're rich and they're struggling
a lot of us are just people and a lot of
us are not rich most of us are not rich
you know most of us are not making a lot
of money we're not getting paid millions
of dollars for our comedy specials
most of us are not um
we don't have a union we don't a lot of
us don't have health care a lot of us
are homeless living from coach couch to
couch
a lot of us you know there are a lot of
comedians in the world and
most of them are not you know chappelle
heart and rock and you know louis ck and
dane cook
most people are just working every day
trying to make a living
doing what they love to do just like
everybody else and just like any other
workforce
some of us
are [ __ ] some of us don't get it
right some of us are racist some of us
are sexist some of us ain't [ __ ] and
some of us are good people
and so
we there there's this active you know
policing of what comedians are saying
um which is fair
if it's applied to everything else
because
i just it's not in comedy
this isn't [ __ ] alone no but i'm saying
you you police comedians but i'm held to
a higher standard than the president of
the united states
and that's a problem that's a great
indicator of where we are because
donald trump said grabbed him by the
[ __ ] and became president
afterwards which
still if he was a comedian and said that
[ __ ] killed that's [ __ ] funny yeah
yeah but when you're the [ __ ]
president you can't be saying stupid
[ __ ] like that she didn't have a phone
or twitter account i don't understand
that's a whole nother thing
but [ __ ] dude when it comes to
i just think that
if it's not from a place of straight
hatred and you're just trying to make
people laugh
it's just [ __ ] laugh at her don't
laugh at it so you know there's a
there's a there's a place between
uh not being able to say anything
and
saying uh
whatever you want right
there are consequences i live by that
because of where the community i grew up
in right there are consequences for what
you say
and i think that
people say whatever they want to say
just know that somebody can punch you in
your mouth you know what i'm saying
exactly but
kat williams made a very good point some
people are really angry because they're
not able to say some of the shitty stuff
that they that they want to say right
there are a lot of people who are lazy
they get they get a laugh at just saying
dumb [ __ ] that is punching down on
people who are defenseless and that that
[ __ ] is is low brow is low common
denominator but i believe that a lot of
things take care of themselves
i don't i don't agree with a lot of [ __ ]
that some of these comedians say i'm not
gonna jump on a board to get them
censored
i'm just like you wanna drop the n-word
my g
go ahead and do that somebody gonna
knock them teeth out your mouth
and that's that's worse than getting uh
canceled on twitter because now you
gotta change your life yeah you know
what i'm saying you got to go get these
teeth again there are some people who
just want to say whatever they want to
say and it's not funny it's not funny
the people who's not funny yeah and the
people who love them are the people who
agree they hate black people they hate
gay people they hate trans people they
whatever but my point is this is just
like
it's it's such a broad group of people
that
you know comedians that go to the punch
lines
and the the improvs and the funny bones
throughout the country that are just
making a couple of thousands of dollars
a weekend that show up on that assembly
line every weekend to entertain people
so you can come and de-stress
that pay the consequences for you being
mad at somebody who's making millions of
dollars and that's not cool
you know i'm always gonna fight for the
common man and woman and person
because
most of us don't don't make that you
know are not wealthy like that and most
of us are imperfect plus
comedians are comedians they usually got
trauma they're damaged why are you
looking to that person for an evolved
point of view
you know she might have made a dick joke
now he's making a
political joke you can't really
use the same guy it's like what do you
think i got to offer you i'm the best
standing on a square box tap dancing for
laughs
something is wrong with me
why do you think i know it all i don't
you're not the only comedian that said
that
joshua said the same [ __ ] but you got to
be kind of [ __ ] up to go up there and
stand up and try to get people to laugh
to be by yourself yeah josh is my god i
love josh but it's the truth it's like
you just standing on a stage by yourself
fifth grade sinking uh oh you like it
you like it [ __ ] yeah i'll keep going
that's really what it is the validation
for all the stuff you didn't get when
you were a little kid
and you want me to know
to give you
a perspective of someone who's whole
dumbass
pay attention to comedians listen to the
stories why they doing what they do
i mean
it's just i don't hate trans people i
don't hate gay people
you know what i mean i don't hate uh
white people i don't hate asians i don't
i mean what i what what what i'm talking
about sometimes do i get it right all
the time maybe not i grew up in the
ghetto of miami going to a school system
where we were sharing books
you know i didn't eat lunch every day
i grew up on wic and food stamps and
some of my teachers gave a [ __ ] most of
them didn't
why do you think i got the answers i got
some jokes for you [ __ ] you don't like
my jokes go go laugh at somebody else
somebody else got your jokes for every
person that doesn't like me there's
somebody who likes pat and oswald we're
very different
that's amazing because i love pat and i
as well too because i know like
i know like if my certain ants come over
you know what
i think you're going to like john
mulaney
yeah
you're gonna like i'm gonna put on john
melanie but all my cousins are here yo
you guys want to watch some [ __ ] up
[ __ ] you guys want to watch a super bad
like tosh.0 type [ __ ]
like i said if you don't like it you
don't have to [ __ ] watch it listen
and if you really wanted to be
that judicious
focus on the legal system right because
if these predators
that you hate that are making music and
i'm not supporting anybody or anyone's
pedophilia but if they would go to jail
and they were held to the law like
they're supposed to you wouldn't hear
this album you wouldn't even know that
they made this comedy special you
wouldn't even know that they are in this
tv show so we need to really focus on
what's important what's more important
is yeah if we can't get them this way
we'll get them this way but we really
need to focus on
the people who are supposed to be doing
what they're supposed to be doing that
affect our communities on a daily basis
and stop putting so much emphasis on
artists and athletes who are usually
people that come from these same
communities who are just finding their
way out
you know what i'm saying and it just it
it gets
and i don't give a [ __ ] if you want to
cancel me for that you know what i'm
saying i don't give a [ __ ] anymore i i
will fight for the the i fight for the
voiceless i'll fight for the the
struggling person my ass off and then
you're going to turn around and [ __ ] on
me
[ __ ] it then i'll i won't i'll just
fight for myself that's how a lot of
people feel
that's exactly how i feel you put it
exactly you put it perfect
it's you can't please everybody
and if somebody's gonna get mad it's
like then don't it's not for you like
what
like i say not everybody watches [ __ ]
football nobody gives a [ __ ] but there's
enough people to keep it going we just
moved in the new set we called it season
two it's not forever it's not for
everybody and let me tell you
my brother loves country music i'm not a
big fan
i have never gone to garth brooks's page
and been like this [ __ ] is trash
you know what i'm saying i don't ever do
that like i don't like thai food
i don't [ __ ] with thai restaurants on
twitter and say you know what you should
die tomorrow because you make thai food
when did your opinion and your
preference become so important that you
think you are you feel so entitled to
tell somebody else who doesn't line up
with that preference that it's more
valuable and that i shouldn't be here
because my point of view is different
than yours what the [ __ ] are you talking
about i think they're looking for
validation from people that agree well
then go do what i'm saying like oh this
guy agree with me see there's 62 people
that agreed with me but now they go like
oh but ain't there a patreon you could
do that [ __ ] all day long and y'all
could circle jerk around each other
and leave us the [ __ ] alone people you
got to remember i'm sorry but 90 of
people are [ __ ] stupid
90 of people just listen to what the
person next to him told him even though
they don't the guy works at the gas
station listen to his political views
it's like yeah you might be smart but
also you can't even come up so i can't
really listen to your ass the [ __ ] out
of here yeah so um november 4th
yes
hbo max is there a time or just
i don't i just think it comes out at
midnight maybe yeah
yeah i'm not sure what this is your
first special congratulations
thanks yeah don't tweet me i won't be on
twitter i won't be on instagram don't
waste your characters because i won't
i'm taking i've taken everything off my
phone as of midnight and
i won't be engaging not for my mental
health i don't if you don't like it
don't watch the [ __ ] you know tell you
know
just but don't i'm not engaging people
i'm not participating in that that's
funny two days ago i went i'm done i'm
just gonna block everybody that's a dick
i'm not gonna respond to people anymore
i just said they shouldn't like there's
not enough time of the day and i don't
give a [ __ ] enough to you he responds to
a thousand comments for every video he
drops yeah but that's just because
everybody's so nice and and i love
[ __ ] talking to our fans but when it
comes to negative [ __ ] i'd literally
just say like then don't [ __ ] watch
it yeah
get out of here it's not for you yeah
that's it is that youtube uh that's how
i feel is it on youtube though what this
the comments that you're talking about
oh yeah we do i mean i have so many
pages i just
for youtube and my other channels i'd
like to do the first thousand comments
but i mean it takes four or five hours
but
i try to look at it as like my daily job
right you know i'm trying to think of it
like you know what
i feel like he's gonna go to sleep like
[ __ ] yeah you responded
it's a mixed bag youtube sometimes
you'll get a comment you know somebody
put a comment onto me one time and they
were like ooh look i didn't know monkeys
could talk damn
somebody told me holy [ __ ] somebody wish
death upon me oh yeah i get that every
day yeah yeah and i'm like you know how
miserable do you have to be i don't like
a lot of people i have never wished
death upon those people though me too
you have to
got to be miserable as [ __ ] yeah
something's going on at home bro
something's bad with you and that's like
giving the benefit of the doubt like i'm
not going to make it any worse so just
leave your ass alone because sometimes
people are [ __ ] mentally unstable
yeah it just takes one person online to
[ __ ] on them and they go well i'm
[ __ ] done that's one thing i always
yeah no i don't i don't i don't want to
get joy out of even
even when i respond you've reached i've
reached my point yeah because i don't
enough to make me go all right
[ __ ] chill out i don't get joy
out of even when people lie on me i
don't defend myself cause i'm like
you came out of nowhere
to lie on me i don't know you
i'm not [ __ ] with that and goes back
to what you say and i think i live by it
you can always get punched in your
[ __ ] face it's facts
it's a fair point it's a fair [ __ ]
point and i always say the people that
talk big online have never been knocked
out in public that's what mike tyson
says does he yeah he's i think there's a
quote like that it says like every
everybody's a tough guy until they get
punched in the [ __ ] mountains oh yeah
yeah you've never been knocked out in
public because you're talking real
[ __ ] reckless right now i've been
punched i've been kicked i lost the
fight you know what i mean that's why i
respect people because i i
and i'm not afraid to fight so i will
always respect people because people who
actually fight don't go around looking
for them because they know that fighting
hurts and it sucks and you go to jail
and you have to go to court you have to
do all this [ __ ] yeah
you could lose a tooth you know you got
you could lose an eye get all scratched
up you can get hepatitis for somebody
scratching like you you know you think
about all the stuff because you've been
in a fight before so you're like yeah
anytime bums get crazy go
i don't want that blood on me i'm just
gonna let you
wave your dick out i'm leaving like
that's pretty much that's the last
incident that happened to me yeah this
guy's crazy
his dick's out i'm good you don't know
where i've been bob
exactly bro that's how i feel like oh
get away um sorry i ended up talking
about bum dicks but you know
it's the this is the show so
thank you so much thank you for slightly
educating me on some [ __ ] too because i
know i need to
expand my brain as the outside of work
editing our show
i we have so much to do so it's like i
know i need to educate myself in some
way and i'll just do it through
different guests so thank you
i'm learning peace by fans have been
asking for that they have something okay
and i know nothing so i listen i'm just
sitting around here just talking you
presented it well enough for me to get
it like all right start locally at least
that's the first piece of information
everyone's ever given me that's i think
that's
the easy the healthiest thing to do easy
easy so
thank you so much thank you for having
me i had a good time november 4th hbo
max go check it out it's called fighting
words easy guys there's [ __ ]
thumbnails on hbo max just
i just got hp on mac so i'm glow i'm
glad
um
yeah all right sober episode i like it
good good
taking all your apps off your phone
thursday night yep
tomorrow night tomorrow night actually
oh today's tuesday november well thank
you so much for being here thank you so
much for uh taking the time to come and
listen thank you to your listeners and
your viewers for just allowing a
different point of view and letting me
just be here because that's what i want
i appreciate people that you know i want
to be able to talk to anybody i don't
ever want to get to the point where i
only talk to people who think like me
because that [ __ ] is boring
and it's unflattering i like i am by
other people's point of views you know i
i learn from that
cool so um since your social medias are
going to be gone
maybe we can just like link the hbo
special i don't know how that works
since it's on the app you can still link
to my social media because i need the
followers oh okay so i'll still be on
yeah i'm just not going to be honest oh
i thought you meant you're you're just
like no no no not going to be on it yeah
okay so all social medias will be linked
in the description
thank you so much thank you appreciate
it guys thank you so much this has been
another episode of the dope as usual
podcast have a dope ass day
i love that name too
that was him that's fire he came up with
that one
i remember everywhere i was sitting when
you text me what about dope as usual
well my my all my youtube stuff is
called dopaziola that's the name um
where's it oh right there on the wall
but i mean just one word flip change the
whole [ __ ] thing
perfect
[Music]
perfect
[Music]